this video is sponsored by keeps which
means we will hear more from them
somewhere in the middle of the video
hello everyone I'm Alana and welcome to
my gaming channel where we do monthly Q
A's all about video games I actually
didn't do one last month for the first
time in like two years just because I
had a boxing fight and I had all this
family stuff going on
um so unfortunately we had to skip last
month but we are back for another month
also sorry if you can hear my dog
chewing in the background I don't have
it in me to stop him first question is
from Eric desito who said hey Alana just
wondering if you've watched the kind of
funny Phil Spencer interview and if yes
can we get your thoughts you know what I
have not let's watch it right now okay
this video is a fair bit longer than I
expected but we will do our best Phil of
course redfall has released from Arcane
Austin and uh it's been a tough release
week for that coming out to low reviews
and a lot of disappointment from many
fans can you talk about that what is
your thoughts right now as we head into
the first week of this game being out
yeah man I'll just I'll just I'll start
not I'll hit I'll hit red fall but I'll
just say all up
um
you know there's there's nothing that's
more difficult for me than disappointing
the Xbox Community just to kind of watch
the community lose confidence be
disappointed I'm disappointed
um I'm upset with myself interesting wow
this is so genuine making revisit our
process usually like like honestly 60
frames props to fill because I feel like
usually the response to that kind of
question is like you know making games
is really hard we're excited to see how
the game develops over the next few
months but he's just like I'm
disappointed that's uh I don't know if
I've ever heard a gaming exec let alone
one is like high up as Phil Spencer
answer a question like that one thing
I'll fight is kind of uh what went wrong
there's clearly quality and execution
things that we can do but one thing I
won't do is push against creative
aspirations of our teams I know a lot of
people will say hey okay yeah it's a
really interesting one redfield's a
really interesting one so I played
redfall before it came out actually let
me go back into feather when I saw the
original gameplay trailers I was like
I'm probably not gonna like this I don't
think this is for me none of the
gameplay really appealed to me a whole
lot and then I got to play it and I was
like oh okay it's actually a little
better than I was expecting my
expectations will very very low and I
found that it had more interesting level
design a more interesting enemy variety
than I was expecting I was expecting
full cookie cutter uninteresting left
for dead clone it had more than that on
the preview and then it came out and it
was what I expected in terms of like I
had fun playing it with friends I
expected that to happen but it's very
hard to find a game that I won't have
fun playing with friends to be honest I
think I like video games more than most
people I like a lot of video games
however the performance was much worse
than I expected
um the performance I would say from the
reviews and even from my own gameplay
was worse than it was in the preview
which I feel like has been happening
like kind of unfortunately often I did
mention when I previewed it that it had
plenty of bugs but like when I spawned
when I played it for the first time I
had
um the fov was locked zoomed in and I
didn't even realize that that bug was
there but we know that redfall was in
development before the Microsoft
acquisition otherwise I would have
guessed that Microsoft has had
contracted them upon acquisition to
release the games
release a certain amount of games per
quarter or per year or whatever that's
what I would have guessed happened with
redfall was that they were like rushed
to pull something out
um but yeah it was in development before
the acquisition I loved death Loop a lot
more than I think a lot of people did I
mean it got 10 out of tens right but I
loved deathly didn't care about redfull
but didn't accept didn't expect it to
get fours and fives I thought it would
get probably sixes and sevens mostly
sevens I just wish they would keep
making pray and Dishonored well games
like that more amounts of Sims man
you've got teams teams know how to do
one kind of game just
force them to go do the one kind of game
okay he's right he's right he's right
um and I'm just not a believer in that
maybe that means I'll I'll under deliver
for some of our fans out there but when
a team like rare wants to do sea of
Thieves when a team like obsidian wants
to do grounded when Tango wants to go do
Hi-Fi when everybody probably thought
they were doing evil the within three
um I want to give the teams really good
point native platform so Paris just
asked basically why didn't they delay
redfull uh when they clearly could have
which I think is a great question Phil's
very deep on this I think
if I think about a team's execution on a
game there's we had a Creative Vision
and did we realize that Vision through
the game that we created
that's not a delay question if the
answer is no that feels like the game
had a goal to do one thing and when
players are actually playing they're not
feeling that thing they're not feeling
the the creative execution of the team
um when a game then just delay it we
start your problems with redfall because
the production but I also didn't expect
it to have this Vision it's a really
interesting one because like I feel like
they got that feedback from the start
maybe it's because I'm kind of out of
the loop with a lot of like gaming
conversations anymore because I I don't
know since I started working in Dev I
pay a lot less attention to like Media
or YouTube commentary on games but I
know my take from all the videos was
that I I was looking forward to playing
Red Bull with friends but that the game
just didn't really appeal to me
was that the general consensus did we
kind of all feel that way
and did they see all that feedback over
the last however many years I guess
redfall's only been being advertised for
like a year and a half two years maybe
two years
and did they just not acknowledge that
feedback or do they think that the
players would take it differently
it's hard to say it is time to talk
about keeps there is no magic cure for
boldness but you can prevent hair loss
from happening in the first place and
the earlier you take action the more
hair you'll keep especially with keeps
in case you didn't already know it keeps
us a subscription service that helps men
keep their hair I have a whole bunch of
friends who use it and love it and vouch
for it and strongly encourage me to work
with keeps because they are so happy
with their results and glad they found
something that works they offer
clinically proven treatments to combat
the symptoms of hair loss and treatments
are delivered straight to customers
doors plus they're affordable usually at
half the cost of Pharmacy prices all
treatment plans are also personalized
and recommended by a licensed medical
provider with a year of unlimited
on-demand access to a dedicated medical
provider with 24 7 expert support
whether you're looking to prevent hair
loss stimulate hair growth or just take
better care of the hair you have keeps
has you covered hair loss stops with
keeps to get a special offer go to
keeps.com Alana Pierce or click the link
in the description that's ke eps.com
Alana Pierce on the score yeah we do
mock reviews for every game that we we
launch and this is like double digits
lower than we thought we would be whoa
um with this game wow that's super
interesting so Phil didn't I guess I
thought the same way he's saying that
they didn't expect
that red Falls mock reviews were nowhere
near as bad as the final release reviews
I felt the same way again even having
played the preview and talking to
everybody who played the preview about
the preview build I think if you like
look at all the previews everyone is
kind of
cautiously optimistic I don't think
anybody raved about it but they were
like here's some stuff in it it's fun
and here's some stuff that I don't like
and everyone was kind of like oh this
might be okay I really would have put
money on sixes and sevens it's super
interesting that the mock reviews said
the same thing I wonder if they played a
different build or maybe if um Arcane
was like hey just so you know this stuff
will be fixed and it was for stuff that
wasn't able to be fixed like that's a
really interesting note I do think that
Xbox is in a really interesting position
right now
um again love how candid Phil is being
here that's awesome that happens so
rarely in games I wish we did it more
often I do think
Xbox fell behind PlayStation in The Lost
Generation
and I've always felt that that's in
terms of video games and that they're
functional that goals seem to be very
different or at least it appears that
way to me that PlayStation is in the
market of making big budget cinematic
very big budget video games that sell
like hot cakes um that you play for 20
plus hours and they say the reason you
need to have a PlayStation is because
that's the only place you can get these
Incredible video games I felt recently
that Xbox was in a completely different
category and almost not even competing
um that they seem to be going for uh
cloud service which um Phil actually
mentioned earlier in this video he said
the reason that they didn't pass sorry
the the Activision deal didn't get
paused in the UK was specifically
because the UK board I'm sorry I'm so
out of the loop on one of the
terminology is the UK board felt that
they had an advantage in cloud gaming
which I would think they do being that
currently the other two parties aren't
anywhere near as focused on that so it
appeared to me that Xbox's Direction was
cloud gaming and subscription obviously
being Game Pass which is also
technically a cloud gaming service so
when you're focused on those things and
you're focused on games you can play on
the go you're not focused on releasing
huge big budget 10 out of 10 AAA video
games that make people buy your box
you're focused on having as many options
as possible that people can play as many
places as possible it's a very different
strategy so I kind of felt like the two
weren't even competing everybody has a
phone if you can get everybody
playing video games globally on your
service for however many dollars a month
is so much so much money in that and I
can understand rationally from a
business perspective why you may not say
we need to have these 10 out of 10
Blockbuster video games
um which I don't love I mean I'm talking
about I don't know but I don't love
because I like the 10 out of 10
Blockbuster AAA video games that I get
to play on my couch but that is what I
had assumed is going on at Xbox right
now that is what I had thought was that
strategy at the moment and how they
differ from both Nintendo and
Playstation in terms of their current
output they don't necessarily need you
to buy an Xbox they want you to buy game
pass because you can play the same
things on PC you don't even need to buy
a console you can play stuff on your
phone now you don't even need to buy a
console and that's okay because I didn't
feel like that's what they've been
trying to do back to the video I've been
a big believer in what Xbox has been
building since about 2016 right Xbox
play Anywhere Game Pass what you're
doing with the series X and S just the
cloud initiative everything I love all
the services
and the and the marketing message that I
suppose does have great services but to
your point and for me personally I have
game pass my kids play it we all love it
but you like you even mentioned
delivering quality experiences every
quarter things like that
that's the sentiment that we get from
the community right now that's the
sentiment that I even have of it's great
to talk about these things I think we've
been talking about the magnasium
it's like where are we gonna get to that
point of actually delivering these
experiences like we I just ran down
those games there's 20 something Studios
forget Activision Xbox game studios what
it is today there's more than enough
Studios and titles out there that we're
all anticipating and it's
I'm also a big fan of Xbox offices
um but that that games aren't there
right now and
My head goes to Psychonauts 2 is the
most recent game that they published
that I really loved oh no tunic I think
I love tunic obsessed with you it's
incredible I think it was my game of the
year last year I loved it
um but outside of that Paris is
basically sharing the sentiments that
like yes you have all these cool
services and that's great but where are
all the games
and yeah I feel like Xbox after the 360
era is very much in their acquisition
era where they've purchased a lot of
Studios we know they have a lot of
Studios we don't know what all these
studios are working on necessarily some
of the things as they mentioned before
that we do know they're working on we
haven't heard about for a while it
almost seems like to me that they are
focused on the Next Generation but
that's not really a promise for anyone
who's a current consumer but that would
be my guess it's like they right now are
focused on what's next
um not the Xbox series XS era
necessarily unless that picks up at the
tail end of the console generation which
has happened before it's totally
possible I think it's not a huge the
comment it's like not a lot of that Ico
very high scoring releases it's like
we're tired of hearing wait till next
year this year started out well yeah yes
developer direct was received while the
team did a really good job I thought
with the messaging around set to your
point around setting expectation and I
will even say yes I'm in um I'm rooting
for the home team here but I'll say over
delivering on expectations of that show
versus what it was I think the drop of
Hi-Fi to say hey if I was really good
too actually sorry I forgot that high
five well Phil we don't have much time
with you so I'm going to go around the
table give everybody one final question
for Phil I'm going to Rattle off a
couple quick ones with you Phil I want
to praise you and the team for really
elevating the PC side of this Xbox
ecosystem I think we've seen a lot of
great strides in that but when you see
the community talk about the console
side of things do you think you've lost
the focus or maybe put too much onto the
PC side do you think that the console is
still getting the console love that it
deserves I will say this might be
disruptive as well
um we have a different Vision you know
Paris talked about this it's play the
games you want with the people you want
that's what I was saying that I don't
think on Xbox that's exactly how I felt
like they've approached this generation
which is um XBox
that vision isn't to sell consoles it's
just not that anymore so the whole
approach is different
um which might lean into why there have
been some less satisfying releases but
Phil does make a great Point Hi-Fi Rush
was fantastic and people loved it got
tons of players obviously Starfield is
probably one of the most talked about
games the last several years
um that is still there we're not in the
business of out consoling Sony or out
consoing Nintendo
um there isn't I think they were a great
solution or win for us and I know that
will upset a ton of people but it's just
the truth
but that's not what they're doing it's
clear it's so clear and the console
two players are as strong as they are
and have
um in certain cases
very just discreet focus on doing deals
and other things that will
um that kind of make being Xbox hard for
us as a team that's on us not on anybody
else
and they're a first-class citizen
they've invested see commentary that if
you just build great games everything
would turn around it's just not true
that if we go off and build great games
all of a sudden you're going to see
console share shift in some dramatic way
we lost
the worst generation to lose in the Xbox
one generation wow everybody built their
Digital Library of games
um so when you go and you're building on
Xbox we want our Xbox Community to feel
awesome but this idea that if we just
focused more on great when people
started really getting digital libraries
with that last generation
um that meant that you know I still own
every PlayStation game that I bought
from that year obviously Xbox as well
but uh I didn't I didn't expect to hear
Philip say that they think they lost
that
um but it's a really interesting comment
to reflect on if like they didn't
capitalize on the appeal of digital
video games in that era where you know
that that first conference which wasn't
Phil was um All About TV and all that
stuff just stuff that people didn't
really want where it should have
probably focused on just making a huge
Digital Library so people are stuck with
your platform which is kind of the case
for a lot of PlayStation games I guess
it was like for all the appeal of game
pause which again I do think is awesome
I love game pause it doesn't matter to
me that red foal didn't perform great
because I was like I don't really have
to pay for it what do I get but uh
people who are on PlayStation are very
unlikely to want them to move
um Nintendo's a little bit different
obviously because it's handheld I think
I think they they operate very
differently but the other two have very
much capitalized on exactly what it is
they're trying to do I still understand
Xbox's Vision but I also think Phil's
right that they're not going to just
suddenly get everybody to go out and
purchase com consoles at this point
because the landscape is so different I
see a lot of pundits out there that kind
of want to go back to the time where we
all had cartridges and discs and every
new generation was a clean slate and you
could switch yeah he's right console
share yeah it doesn't work that way now
that we are in today and I haven't had
anyone say that he's obviously he's
right but it's super interesting yeah I
mean so the question I think you asked
me so long ago
was something about
what do I think is going on at Xbox and
I think he's answered it um it was half
what I expected which is that they're
focused on cloud and subscription
services and they're not playing the
console game which is the thing I've
been saying for ages there is no console
war anymore they're not it's not the
same thing they have different goals
um and also just yeah I didn't expect
Phil to lay that out so candidly full
respect to him for everything he's
saying here and to the kind of funny
team for asking such great questions
that was super interesting
um and I just I feel like a level of
transparency we so rarely get in video
games which is so nice more of this
please
um okay moving on run for me like said
hey Alana just wondering what your most
anticipated games to the remainder of
2023 are great question I actually keep
forgetting what's coming out this year
I've really immediately excited about
Diablo
I'm quite excited about System Shock at
the end of this month
um those are two games that are coming
out within the next month though
obviously like
sort of at the opposite of recency bias
really excited about both of them I
think I'm going to spend a lot of time
in Diablo let's look up game releases
yeah so the System Shock reboot is May
30 Diablo 4 is June 6. I can't wait it
actually just sucks that Diablo 4 is
like right around the same time
as the E3 stuff starts here in La ugh
oxen free too I'm really looking forward
to
uh that's July 12th I loved oxen free
Baldur's Gate 3 August 31st definitely
looking forward to that PS5 and PC
Starfield obviously September 6th and
I'm actually pretty curious to see where
I land on Starfield I really like outer
worlds um
I'm a very big Fallout person not as big
of an Elder Scrolls person I don't know
why I just always I love Fantasy games I
just really preferred Fallout although I
didn't love the most recent two editions
to that franchise quite as much so style
feel like it kind of go either way
I actually don't know how well I feel
about it but I have no doubt that it
will consume a whole lot of all of our
time so definitely anticipated I just
can't be like oh my God I want it right
now in the way that I feel about Diablo
4. Alan Wake too that's a big one very
excited about that that doesn't have a
release date yet I'm really looking
forward to it especially the direction
that they've had in Ahmed core six very
excited about that black myth Wukong is
supposed to come out this year also
excited about that I don't know if that
one is really going to come out this
year that game feels like it doesn't
even exist oh I'm really looking forward
to the cyberpunk DLC Final Fantasy Final
Fantasy 16. that is very high up and
also coming out next month right I think
that's also pretty close definitely
looking forward to that one and that's
everything that comes to mind oh yeah we
may be getting Final Fantasy 7 rebook
this year too which would be pretty huge
oh Marvel Spider-Man 2 doesn't have a
release date yet that's exciting
we'll have a bolt gun that comes out
next week very excited about Warhammer
bolt gun I'm less interested in Space
Marine too personally
Wolf Among Us two and wild Hearts is
also a good one
there's I'm sure there are other things
that I've forgotten about but um doesn't
feel like that huge of a year this year
for some reason I don't know why I feel
that way but uh I would be surprised if
like majority of my gaming hours this
year don't go to Diablo and Zello to be
honest and that's really all we have
time for because I spent so much time on
the Xbox part
thank you for watching this video we
will be back with another q a next month
if you want to leave questions in the
comments below you can do that or I will
link to where you can leave questions
for my IRL Channel I probably have to
put a new q a up there next week or the
week after as well so I'll see you guys
next time bye